okay hi everyone um welcome back to
we're now in past the halfway point week
six of cs 224 n um
and so let me just give um a
couple of quick announcements first um
so today is the day
that you have to have done the mid um
quarter survey by hundreds of people
have but if you haven't this is your
last chance um to get the half point for
that
today is also the day um that final
project proposals are due
we really encourage you to try and hand
them in on time or nearly on time that's
really just to help you so we can more
quickly give you feedback on final
project proposals um and in the
background then there's also assignment
five you will have seen the message that
we're giving you one extra day for that
but we do certainly encourage you to be
hard at work on assignment five at this
point hopefully it's a great exciting
opportunity to be learning all the
latest stuff about transformers
and then today i'm delighted to have our
first invited speaker um let me just
mention that going along within
the
half point of participation credit um
is you guys writing a reaction paragraph
talking about something um that the
speaker talks about and their
instructions upper for that um on ed um
but without further ado
let me introduce dante chen um so dante
is one of the foremost researchers in
question answering and she's
particularly well known um in recent
work
for being one of the co-authors of the
roberta paper the spanbert paper and on
using dense passage retrieval
methods for open domain question
answering and as a professor at the um
princeton university um but as one other
comment um don she once upon a time was
the head ta of cs224n
um so she's quite familiar um with the
context of this class um so i'm really
delighted to have done she here to give
this lecture on question answering
thanks
thank you chris for the introduction um
for me it's a very good it's a great
opportunity for me to come back to
cs2201 today and give this lecture also
b virtually
so question answering the areas that
have been working quite a bit in the
last few years so today i'm very happy
to introduce you some of the
fundamentals in this field as well as
some cutting edge and save our topics
so here is my plan for this lecture
so first i will be um give a brief
introduction of what is question
answering and what kind of problems that
people are starting today
so i'm going to spend the most of this
lecture focus on one type of question
answering problems called reading
comprehension so this is basically
problems of how we build systems to
answer questions over a single passive
text
so i know that many of you are going to
do a default project on the stanford
question answering data set so
understanding this part will be very
crucial for your final project
so at the end of this lecture i'm hoping
to spend like hopefully like 20-ish
minutes to talk about a more practical
and in my opinion or more exciting
problem called open domain question
answering so we will try to answer
questions over a very large collection
of the documents
and i so my friends try to quickly go
over some of those state art methods in
this area
okay so let's just get started
so first what is the question answering
so the goal of question answering is to
build systems that can automatically
answer questions posed by humans in a
natural language
question answering all let's say qa in
short is one of the earliest mlk tasks
and the early systems can even date back
to 1960s
so here is one example of the early like
one of the early um qa systems uh qa
systems in back to 1964. so as you can
see that this system is trying to answer
a question like what do you want it and
then finally return on the answer that's
the graph
so to do this so this system is
basically trying to find some kind of
text matching between the question and
some kind of text segments and by using
some kind of dependency analysis i
assume that you have already learned the
defense parsing in this class
and there are many different types of
the question answering problems and we
can also we can categorize all these
question answer problems based on the
either information source or the titles
of questions or the type of answers
so for the information source we can
build a system that can put like a
condition on um
a short passive test or a very large
collection of documents or even like a
structured database or structured
knowledge base
basis or even tables or images
so for the question type we can also be
assistants that can answer like factory
questions or non-factory questions or
open domain questions or close domain
questions or simple questions versus
like more complex or compositional
questions
and for the answer type it can also be
like a short segment or text or a
paragraph or document or list or even
the yes or no questions
so just have in mind there's many
different types of question answering
problems and all these problems may
require very different techniques or
different data or even different
evaluation metrics to
divide all these different problems
and the question counselor has enabled a
lot of the useful real world
applications
for example today if you just put your
question in a search engine like google
so for example you can put in your
question like where is the deepest lake
in the world
so you can see that the current system
basically found a like a short
snippet of text
including like
lake um
by carl barco in siberia calls the
distinction of being both the deepest
lake in the world and the largest fresh
water lake blah blah and then it can
actually pinpoint the correct answer
which is actually a concise entrepreneur
which should be siberia
and those kind of systems are also able
to handle like more complex questions
like how to questions i guess this is
probably a question that everyone
currently cares about so the question is
how can i protect myself from kobe 19.
so there isn't really a simple and short
answer to this question
so you can see that the system actually
returns a very long
including the best way to prevent the
illness is to avoid being exposed to
this virus and to help prevent the
spirit of kobe 19 you can do the
following so actually the
this paragraph is actually a summary uh
from this
cdcsco if you just click this link and
read through the article so this is also
one like one type of question answering
problems
and now this is a survey of the use
cases for the current digital systems
such as alexa or google home
so according to this survey result in
january 2020 which is one year ago so
you can see that also people actually
really like to ask questions um this is
on this digital assistant so you can see
the question is actually the
second most used case only ranks after
the listening to music and the before
the checkered weather instead of time
timer so questions have been really
useful in this virtual assistants
another very famous example of the
question answering system is this ibm
was from question 3 system so in 1920
or 2011 so this idea was because qa
system has been shown to beat two
national japanese champions in answering
deathly questions
so this is kind of this uh like a
historical event
at least in the lp history
so if we look at the era working of this
kind of system more closely so you can
see that it is actually a very
complicated and highly modularized
system
so if the system is built on both the
unstructured text and also the
structured data
so by looking at the system if you go
from the left to right you can see that
this system consists of the four stages
including the question processing
the candidate answer generation and the
candidate answer scoring and the
confidence merging ranking and then if
you look at each stage you can see that
there are many different nlp techniques
that have been actually included in this
complex query system including a
question classification
parsing relation extraction correference
so it's actually there are really lots
of the lpcs modules that have been
included
and now this system has been over 10
years or actually exactly 10 years now
and this is actually representing the
space art like 10 years ago at that time
so we know that this class is about deep
learning
so today differently has completely
really transformed the landscape of the
question answering systems
so there's no doubt that we can say that
almost all the states are personalizing
systems today are built on top of the
end-to-end training of the diploma
networks and approach and language
models such as bird so today in this
lecture we are also going to learn a lot
of these deep learning models in full
question answering
and this statement is probably also true
for almost all the nlp problems that we
can see today but we can also argue that
question answering is probably one of
those fields that we have seen the most
recovered remarkable progress in the
last couple of years driven by
deployment
so in this lecture uh i'm i'll be mostly
focused on like uh focusing on the text
based on textual uh crash answering
problems so basically we are trying to
answer questions based on the
unstructured text so before i get
started i jump to that part i also want
to quickly point out that there are many
other really big questions problems and
each of them can be a really like a big
star sub field in nlp and they actually
have very different challenges and also
model designs
so one bigger class of this crash answer
problem is this knowledge based question
stream so basically we want to build
question also in systems to answer
questions that can answer
also questions over a very large
database
so to solve this problem some approaches
need to take this question
and convert this question into some kind
of larger forms and this kind of logic
forms can be executed against this
database to give you the final answer
and then another class the bigger class
of the presentation problem is called
visual question answering so it's
basically you need to answer questions
based on the images
so this problem this requires both
understanding of the questions and also
images and there is actually a very
active field between the computer vision
and our key so if you are interested
with this type of problems i encourage
you to check out these problems but i'm
not going to dig into these problems
today
okay so next i'm going to start with the
part 2 reading comprehension
i just want to quickly check if there
any quick questions i can
answer before i get started um starts
will catch you yeah no i think we could
do now
okay so yeah so let's talk about the
reading comprehension then
so reading commemoration is the basic
problem that we want to compare
a passive text and answer questions
about the content
so the input of this problem is
basically a passive text a question and
the goal is to return the answer that
actually can answer this question
so here's one example
so let's tell so here is a passive text
and we want to uh answer a question the
question is what language your test will
study while you score
okay so i'm going to pause like 5 10 or
10 seconds and see if people can find
the answer to this question
based on this passage
and you guys
um okay what people say to german
yeah germany
so the answer should be german so
basically to answer this question so you
need to find this sentence like in 1861
tesla attended this school where he
started german arithmetic and a religion
and it's only the german the language so
the answer to this question should be
german
okay here is another example again
another passive text and the question is
which linguistic minority larger hindi
or
mala um
i think yeah
five seconds
okay so the answer to this question
should be hindi so this
probably is not a very hard question for
humans it's actually a pretty hard
question for machines because to get
this question correctly so the machines
basically to understand that for the
hindi like three point three percent of
the population speaks of hindi and only
like one point twenty seven percent
speaks uh mala yellen this language and
then also compare these two numbers and
the final case uh three percent three
point three percent is a bigger number
so the answer should be hindi to this
question
okay so next i'm going to talk a little
bit so why do we care about this problem
so why do we care about the reading
comprehension problem so besides that it
actually
drives many useful real world practical
applications
also as i've already shown some examples
at the beginning i think there are also
two other key reasons
so the first reason also besides
adaptation the first reasons is
so reading comprehension has been also
viewed as a very important testbed for
evaluating how well computer systems
understand human language so this is
really just similar to like um how we
humans actually test the reading
comprehension test to uh to evaluate how
well we actually understand about
language so this is also the way that we
actually um pose questions to test the
machines that would understand language
understandings of ability so this
actually has been formally stated in um
back in 1977 by benny leonard in her
dissertation so she didn't saying is she
says that
these questions can be devised to query
any aspect of text comprehension so
ability to answer questions is the
strongest possible demonstration of
understanding so that's why reading
comprehension can be a very important
testbed because we can't divide design
very complex complex questions to test
that
and also i think there's another
interesting and important reason that um
reading comprehension is important so in
the recent few years so many some
researchers actually found that okay so
for many other nlp tasks that we can
also reduce them to a reading
comprehension problem so i'm going to
give you two examples
so one example is really information
extraction so basically if we want to um
so given on the person like subject
barack obama given a relation educated
at
so we want to fill in what is fill in
this question mark and figure out okay
where barack obama was advocating that
so one one way to solve this problem is
basically trying to
convert this relation into a question so
where did barack obama graduate from and
taking a relevant piece of text and then
by applying a reading comprehension
problem then basically the we can find
out the extract the correct answer
should be columbia university that is
also the output of this information
extraction system
another example is actually called
cementite labeling i'm not sure if i've
learned this in the past yet probably
not but this is a task of the spanish
labeling is trying to taking one
sentence and trying to identify the
rules for different verbs at least for
words in this case in the in one
sentence so basically trying to give
them one sentence about given one verb
finish trying to figure out like who did
what you and when and where
so by trying to um so it's going to try
to figure out um all these like rules um
with respect to the verbs so one way to
solve this problem is by also by
converting all these different roles
into questions
such as who finished something what did
some someone finish and what did someone
finish something else so by converting
all these kind of like um
semantic error relations well we can
also apply just apply the ring
comprehension problem and give you the
correct answer so this is actually a
very interesting perspective that
reading comprehension can be actually
very universally useful to many other
tasks
so next
i'm going to introduce this like a
stanford question string dataset cause
god so if you are going to do the
default final projects you will need to
use this data set
so cylindrical questions and datasets is
actually a supervised reading
comprehension dataset so which consists
of 100k
annotated passage and the answer
question also triples so here is one
example from this data set
and uh i just want to um
say that also one important thing to
have in mind is that uh so this dataset
has consists of 100k annotated examples
and this kind of large-scale supervised
dataset are also very key
key ingredient for the training the
effective neural models for reading
comprehension so after the data set many
other like later data sets have been
also collected um basically runs this
size around like 100k so 100k is
actually very important um to transit
neural models so for these data sets
so the passages is like a single passage
a single paragraph selected from the
english wikipedia which usually consists
of like 100 to 150 words and the
questions are power sourced um basically
electronic kind of perking
and there is a very important property
of this data set is
that each answer is a short segment text
or we could spend in the passage so as
you can see from this example so here
are three different questions and each
of this um answer can be actually found
as a short segment text in the passage
so this is actually a pretty
interesting property i know it's also
important important property
of this data set but also just to uh
tavis that this is also a limitation
because not all the questions can be uh
answered use in this way so only the
questions that that you can find the
answer as a spell in the passage can
actually be included in this data set
basically
but today so this data um
yeah i forgot to say so this data set
was collected in 2016 by several you
know researchers at stanford so it's
called stanford question three data sets
um today like after four or five years
now so school still remains the most
popular reading comprehension dataset so
it's actually you know very clean on the
high quality day set but it's also not
as very difficult dataset so today is
basically the score data status set has
been almost sold and the saves are
already exists estimating the human
performance
and i also want to quickly mention the
evaluation for this uh
stanford credit counseling data set
so there are basically two evaluation
metrics to evaluate how well a system
can do on this data set the two metrics
uh uh let's see if match and a1 score so
when you sign match is basically just a
binary indicator zero one uh based on
measures whether the answer can actually
be exactly matched to the gold answer
and the eighth line score basically
measures kind of some partial credit
enough to do the evaluation so basically
for the development and testing set
there will be like three gold answers
collected because um
for some questions there might be not
just one unique answer so there could be
multiple possible answers
and the eventual matrix basically takes
a pretty good answer and compares or
compares the predicted answer to each
code answer with some kind of like
some articles and also the permutations
included and obviously you can computer
exact match score and also a fine score
by comparing come back comparing the
predicted answer to the gold answer and
then finally take the next course and um
because there are many different
examples in the demo or test set and now
finally we just take the average of all
the examples for the poster exact match
and the reference score
so by using this evaluation method
the estimated human performance is um by
the researchers at that time uh
estimated by the researchers at the time
is the exact match score is 82.3 percent
and the f1 score is 91.2
so here is just a quick
example so here the question what did
tesla do in december 1878
and there are three possible answers so
if i see that the first two answers are
the same left grass and the third answer
is left breath and as uh serve i think
that type of fear um all really
relations with his family and then you
feel in front of prediction is uh spent
which is left breath and serve
so you can see that the exact there
isn't an exact match spot between the
predicted answer and any of the answer
so the exact match will be zero and the
a5 score will be uh taking the max i'm
not going to talk about how these are
computed
so i suggest you check out the original
paper so by computing this course and
taking the max and the the final is the
f1 score will be 0.667
which is a f1 score for this creative
answer on this data set
so dante one question you might answer
is so if you can do other tasks like
named entity recognition or relation
extraction by sticking something on top
of bird as and fine-tuning for it or do
it as question answering does one or the
other method work better and by how much
um that's an interesting question um
so i haven't really seen that okay since
there has been some claims that okay all
the uh tasks can be converted into
questions and tasks but i'm not sure
there is a really like a very fair
comparison let's say a young and
anti-recognition and by really
converting that into question answering
tasks so i don't have to answer to that
so the kind of state art and your system
is still trying to just change or
sequence tagger uh tagging on top of the
bird so yeah i don't really have a
preset something like that
should i continue
okay
okay so next i'm going to talk about how
to build a
neural models for reading comprehension
in particular how we can build a model
to solve this standard questions in
datasets called dataset i also want to
just quickly mention that um because
there are many different papers it
actually uses like um
different notions to refer the same
thing so starting from um so i'm going
to use the passage paragraphs in context
and also question the query basically
interchangeably so they are basically
referred to the sentencing because
different papers use also different
notions so i just want to quickly
mention that
okay so how can we build a model to
solve this problem
so let's first formulate this problem
so the input of this problem is uh let's
take let's take a context or paragraph
so c which consists of the n tokens c
one to c n
and also we take a question q and the
question uh consists of m tokens q one
to q m
so um could be something like around 100
to um between 100 and 200 for spot and
the m would be much shorter would be
something like 10 or 15.
and then because the answer has these
constraints as the answer must be your
second text in the passage so the output
can be just uh
written this way so we are going to
predict the start and end
so start and then end will be arranged
um
in the range between the one
so it is basically just two check points
oh sorry two end the point of the answer
and um
so scott has been collected back in late
2016. so after uh 2016 there have been
like visit two families of the
models neural models to solve this uh to
solving this like stem score data set so
the first family basically like uh there
are a lot of models that come out during
that period between 2016 and 2018.
so this my family models figure i always
can base models with attention
so these are like just like a list of
the representing models that come out
during that period and including some
work that i did when i was a phd student
at stanford
and now the second
the second class models i put here is
really there that divided here before
the version after birth so
after birth came out so almost those
other this reading comprehension models
were built on like how to find two of
the bird models not just for model size
for the birth life models so prediction
language models and for these kind of
reading comprehension problems
so here are like two um the
sound is uh the illustrations of these
two families of the models so on the
left is like iostm based models
resultation and on the right is on the
burton model um
and then we need to fine-tune this model
for the question for the reading
comprehension task so i know that for
the
so my plan today is first try to talk
about to talk about these ios 10 based
models so i'm going to spend a little
bit more time on this part because i
know that um for the default final
project you need to implement this model
furthest from the scratch so i'm going
to work through how to build this model
like step by step and hopefully that you
can have a good understanding of how
this model works and then i'm just going
to briefly talk about how
to build this use the bird models for
the ring comprehension
okay so before i start talking about
these lstm models i know that you have
already learned this sequential sequence
models without tension for machine
translation
so i was um so i want to draw some
connections between the machine
translation problem the reading
comprehension problem because they
really share a lot of similarities
so first
uh so in the machine translation model
or this like sequence use sequence model
there is a source and package sentence
so basically us two sequences
so but in our case in this reading
comprehension case that we also have two
sequences one is a passage and another
is a question but the length could be a
slightly imbalance because the passage
will be much longer than the question
but there are essentially also two
sequences
and then
so in the reading comprehension we need
to model like which words in the passage
are most relevant to the question and
then if they're irrelevant to the
question so all is also relevant to
which which set of the question words so
this is basically
uh very key important thing that the
important thing that we actually need to
model
and this is actually very similar to the
machine translation model that we need
to model
which words in the source sentence that
actually are most relevant to the
current packet word so you can imagine
that the attention will be also really
the key ingredient here is that just
like some new sequence 26 model we need
to model the attention between the
source sentence and the target sentence
we also need to model the attention
between the passage and the question so
this is actually very similar
so something that's actually not very
similar is
for the sigma 6 model we need to build
on like a decoder auto regressive
decoder to generate the target sentence
word by word but in this reading
comprehension problem we we don't need
to really generate anything so we just
take the test and take the question so
at least for the school
data set we just need to change two
class files to predict the start and end
positions of the answer
so that that part is actually simplified
so when you don't need to change the
decoder to generate the target sentence
okay so next i'm going to talk about one
um this model colored by def so it
stands for bi-directional attention flow
for machine comprehension so it was
proposed by means seal and other folks
in 2017 so it remains before the ice
before the bird came out it remains one
of the most popular reading
comprehension models and achieved very
good performance at that time at least
on the small data set
so you can see that this model
like seems to be pretty complicated but
if you um look uh look at this model
from the bottom to the top it actually
can be decomposed um into many different
layers
so the next i'm going to just dissect or
dissect this model layer by layer and
talk about okay what these layers are
actually doing and how we can really
build this model from the bottom layer
to the top layer and then finally
transition like model you know enter
anyway
okay so the first uh chart is actually
the bottom three layers
um called the character embedding layer
word embedding layer and the phrase
embedded layer so i just put them
together because this is an encoding
function
so the idea here is that okay let's take
the context query or the passage in
question we need to encode them
separately
so to do this
so this model basically proposed to use
a concatenation of the word embedding as
well as the character embedding
for each word in the context and the
query so for the word embedding is
straightforward so if you have you have
learned word embeddings so you can just
look up the word for the this word like
seattle just use the global embedding
as a reputation for this word
and the for the character embedding part
so you basically need to
represent each character in this world
like seattle and a bypasses to a
convolutional neural network with some
kind of max pooling operations and then
finally you can just get one reputation
at the top and then you just concatenate
its own uh word embedding and the
calculating body
so these kind of embeddings have been
shown effectively to improve the
replication for the unseen or the real
words
so mathematically mathematically you can
see that
for each word in the context of query
you can just we can just represent this
uh rotation as blocks of the embedding
and the character embedding and then we
just concatenate them and pass this to
like all highway networks so i don't
write the function here so um so you can
just look at orange on
paper and the second part um for other
we call it the issue very visual word
so on the next we are going to pass this
like word embedding into two separate
bi-directional lstms to separately to
produce these contextualized embeddings
for both the context and query
so
let's look at this equation so we take
the uh reputation of this word and we
just uh basically this is like a one
lstm model uh from one direction and
this all always can model from another
direction so we just need to competent
the two um the two header rotations two
directions and finally we can get a
contextualized rotation for for this for
each single word in the context and now
we can do the same similar thing for the
question um reputation
i also want to quickly mention because i
mentioned the sequential sequence model
the sequence just sigma although we
cannot really do this bi-directional
stems for the two sequences again like
because the decoder is all
auto-regressive model so that's why the
decoder is usually just implemented as a
unidirectional stem but because here we
don't really care about the generation
so we can just use two bi-directional
scans to represent the rotations this is
actually very important
uh this bi-directional length is
actually very important to capture the
contacts from both the left and right
side
okay so the next component is the next
layer it's called the attention flow
layer so i just call it attention here
so the change idea the idea of attention
is trying to capture
the interactions between the contacts
and query and nothing in this paper by
that favor they they propose two types
of attention
so the first type of tension we call the
context require attention
so the idea is
for each context word
can we find some most relevant words
in the question
from the question for the query for the
query words so here's one example so
here the context context of barack obama
is the president of the usa
so for each context word we need to find
an alignment but define like which words
in the question can be actually aligned
with this context word so we can see
that both barack obama can be aligned to
who and the president is aligned to
release and the usa alliance united
states so busy for each content will try
to find the most relevant query words
another second type of tension is called
query to context or tension so it's very
another direction so here the idea is to
choose some context words that are most
relevant to
one of the prior words because the
context can be very long
so a lot of the context could be just
not relevant to the this question so we
just run over around several examples
you can see that the first thing we need
to do is try to locate okay which parts
of the sentences in this context can be
actually relevant to this question so
this type of the query to context or
attention is trying to capture
so which um
which context words actually can be most
relevant to
to the query to one of the query words
so for this example the question is
which city is grooming in winter so you
because the question is asked about
blooming so you can find priority
figures okay blue means it speeches
is actually very relevant to this
question
and now we also find this in winter
because in winter it also mentions the
question
so this particular um context was to be
also relevant to this question so this
um
context words could be probably need to
capture and uh in this attention that
okay this is actually relevant to this
question
okay so this is actually basically just
an intuition of these two types of
tension
and this is also why this model is
called a bi-directional attention flow
because there is a contrast required
attention and there is also a library to
context attention
so let me just talk about go through how
to actually um
uh
do this like curve to context attention
the contextual periodic tension in this
model
so the way they do this is first
to compute a similarities form
for every pair of the contextualized
vector ci
and for every pair of the question with
qj so this is actually the output from
the encoding layer so this is already
the output from the lstm layers
and the wizard is basically just
computer similarities form
by taking the ci
qj
and also the element-wise multiplication
of the c and qj
so they basically just concatenate these
three vectors so the output will be a
sixth h dimensional vector and they just
multiply this to um compute the dot
product of another like a learnable
vector and then finally just discard
this basic can give you one scalar one
number the sij which measures how um the
similarity between this context where ci
and also this question were qj so if you
i have so if i learned some attention
before so this is actually just one
choice of this model so there could be
many different ways to define this uh
similarity and uh similarity scores so
this is basically just one design choice
of this model
okay so after defining this margins for
sij
so the context to create attention again
like which question words are most
relevant to ci
so the way to do this is so basically
just taking this matrix the similarities
for sij
for each row we should basically
correspond to like one context word for
each row
um
so they are going to compute the soft
max for each row and this can give us
like um normalization force alpha ij
which is our probability distribution
over all the question words fij
so this is just really similar to all
the attention uh mechanisms that you
probably have seen in this class so
basically for each context we're taking
the soft max um
um
over all the question words and get us
um probability distribution and then
finally just take the linear combination
of the
weighted combination of these are
tensions for r i j and also the question
vector the q j and then finally you can
get a vector a i which is actually a 2h
dimensional vector so this query context
shows quite retention basically just try
to capture which questions words are
most relevant to each context word
so the next five part is a paragraph um
sorry the title here sorry uh this is
actually the query to context or
attention so which means that which
context words are relevant to some
question words so we don't so a lot of
context words would be not relevant to
this question so the idea to do this to
do this is for each row of this sij this
busy just takes a math scores
over all the um question words and after
taking this back score to compute the
softmax over all the context words here
so here i actually numerous over all the
context words and this can give us like
attention another attention score beta i
which captures how important this
context works is relevant to this
question
so after computing this beta i
so we can again like compute this like a
weighted combination
by um computing by um
somewhere by summing up the beta i and
also the context context vector ci and
then finally we can get our vector bi
which is also another 2h dimensional
vector
and the final output of this attention
function is actually very complicated
here is also the design choice of this
model
so the takes a context measure ci
and as it takes ai from this part of the
context to query retention
and that takes the element from
multiplication between the c and ai and
also the cnbi and finally take the
concatenation and it can give you a
produce or h dimensional vector
okay maybe i want to pause a little bit
and check if there are any questions
because it's probably a little bit
complicated
one question
is why is query to context and context
of query attention not symmetrical
um um
that's a good question yes uh so here's
essentially the goal you're trying to
because if the goal is final goal is
trying to find a span in the passage so
so to hold the point of the this
attention function you know trying to
produce a rotation for each single
context word in this context
so that's um
so so we are not trying to generate the
question notifications here it's going
to try to generate the um context
orientations so one so the difference
between these two like first let's try
to see which questions words are
relevant to this context word another
part is trying to figure out which
context word can be relevant and which
context would can be not irrelevant
i hope this sounds so answers to a
question
here's an easier question sort of on the
same topic which might help
is there a reason why you use both query
to context and context to query
attention is it sometimes
advantageous or okay to use just one
that's a good question um
the reason is yeah so i'm going to show
some obligations partly from this paper
so they basically just find the both
both directions can really help um by
drawing the context curve context so
there'll be some relation studies so by
using one set is useful but just not as
good as using the both directions
um
right
let's see uh
in the bottom right
we sum over i so why does the i remain
in bi
is that correct or is there a typo there
oh this is not a typo
so again i'm sorry so the output yeah i
know it will be confusing so also output
of this model this com
module is to get a reputation for each
context word at the end so both
the output for ai and bi i is actually
um enumerate from like um actually you
know
if it's over all the context words
so bi will be skills um just try to
aggregate over all the questions on the
over all the context words but the beta
i measures the importance of this kind
of test words
compared to all the context words
so both ai and the bi are actually with
respect to the context words yes so you
can see that here is basically doing
some kind of the
element wise multiplication so the
output of gi will be actually arranged
from from the one to an um which is the
number of the context words
there are lots of questions about this
um what is the rationale for the
expression for gi
how how does one come up with such an
expression
okay i don't know i guess you'll also
try out a lot of things
okay so key point here is trying to
understand okay so the rules of the
contest require attention equality or
context rotation so i bet that there
could be many different formations to do
this i also think the authors have tried
many different
but uh just what they kind of can come
up as and i think that if after week um
there could be some other ways to
incorporate the both attention but it
doesn't have to be written this way
i mean one other question would be in
the query the context attention
why do you do a max
inside the soft max
yeah um yeah sorry i should have
explained this more clearly so here
again query to context or attention to
try to measure
well whether this is the importance of
these context words with respect to some
um some answer question words so if the
so by taking the max
for each row in this ace matrix so it's
basically trying to see okay which
question word um is actually most
relevant to uh this context word if this
number is still very low that means this
there isn't any question words that
could be aligned with this context word
so that this will just if i take after
taking the math if this number is still
very low that means this question
context vote is not very relevant so so
basically just that's why we take the
soft max our price of max on top of the
max
ah i know do you want even more do you
want to go on
uh i probably should well i don't have a
lot of slides but i'm happy on the
questions after afternoons yeah maybe
you should go on
yeah
okay so the last part of this model is
actually um um the either it's the
normal stimulus so it's a two out of
five lastly there are two layers smaller
layer and output layers
so for the modern layer so again for
after the attention layer they take some
heater rotation um
so basic gi
which captures the tension between your
contacts and the query and then
basically just uh passes gi to another
two layers of bi-directional stems
and the many reasons they do this is
the attention layer is basically
modeling the interactions between the
query and context
and now by passing this to another two
layers of bi-directional lstms the
modern layers is basic modeling they can
also first model the interactions using
the context words
so this is a formulation here um so
these are two layers bi-directional stm
by taking the gis input and the output
will be on the mi which is another 2h
dash um
dimensional vector for each context word
in the in the passage
okay so the final is also links so far
other players this is just two class
friends
just trying to predict the start and end
positions
so by doing this so the first contact is
the gi and mi so this would be actually
a 10 h dimensional vector and by
computing the dot product of another
vector called w start and this resulting
vector and they can get basically get a
score
for each
position in the context and then you can
just apply a soft max
and then this will give you a
probability that okay what is the
probability this partition i will be
actually uh
based on
um
the start position of the final answer
string
and they also have something um another
classifier to predict the end position
of the answer but they also did
something a little bit more complicated
so they actually pass the mi to another
bi-directional lstm here so they call it
m i and they compati and m prime i oh
sorry this is the title so this will be
wn
um so they compute the dot product
between wn and this vector and this can
give reproduce our own probability uh
probability over all the positions which
predicts uh um
how likely this position will be the end
position of the answer so by doing it by
passing the mi to another by their
character and the reason that
they're trying to capture some kind of
dependence between the choice of the
start and end so you can imagine that
start and should shouldn't be um too
separate so it shouldn't be could be
independent predicted but if they
declare that if you incur some kind of
dependence between the mi and um just
keep starting and pn this can actually
perform better
okay i'm done with
this part of
describing the bypass model
any quick questions i can answer
i think you can actually go on
okay
okay sorry i forgot to mention this okay
the final training loss
will be just by taking these two
probability distributions and that is
basically just the next negative log
likelihood of the gold as a gold answer
just the
start position of the gold answer and
the position of um the answer and by um
just us um basically taking the
product of these two probabilities but
you apply them uh apply a lot so this is
the sum of the two negative log terms
will be the final chain loss and the
whole the whole model can be just
changing our entry anyway from the
encoding layer to attention layer to
modern layer and to output layer so this
will be just um completes the whole that
the whole model of the by that model
okay
so this model is actually um achieved
like uh on the data set it will achieve
the 77.3 f1 score so as i mentioned
earlier so um 2000 operations started
they found the
the pulsar attention in two directions
are actually important if you usually
move the one direction the performance
will actually drop quite a bit if we
remove the contacts to parallel tension
the performance will drop to sixty seven
point seven eight wave one score and if
you uh remove this part it will drop to
a four point eight point four and then
also the character embeddings can also
help so if you remove the character in
balance you you'll get like a 1.9 uh
point drop
and on the right of this figure you have
um this slide you can see a very big
table so it's basically all the models
that count out at that time between 2016
and 2018 so you can see that um by
definition here so you'll achieve the
77.3 f1 score and the basic all the
models are actually you know a very
similar ballpark so numbers range from
like um
the highest number here 79.8
until like um after the elmo was
introduced the numbers have been
actually improved quite a bit so before
the elbow basically all the numbers are
actually kind of similar so uh each
model actually improves our premise
previous model by like a 1.02 points
and now here is our attention
visualization by uh to show that um how
this like personalities for the tension
actually can capture the similarity
between the question words and context
words so here example the question where
did the super bowl 50 takes play uh
place so the issue is actual
question word here and each column is
matrix basically indicates the attention
score the semantic score that that has
been learned by this model so you can
see that
and the on the right is basically trying
to
uh
print out or display so the
the context words that have the highest
scores
so you can see that the where it has
been aligned very well with uh at the
stadium leva and also the super bowl 50
is basically lined very well with super
bowl 50. so this basically really tells
that this kind of attention scores can
actually capture those merit scores
pretty well
okay so
next i'm going to talk about now how to
use the burden model to solve this
problem
so i know that you have learned the
first in the last lecture so i'm not
going to repeat this so very quick so
bert is basically a deep directional
transformer including pre-trained on the
large amount of text and in the channel
the two training objectives including
masculine modeling and the next sentence
prediction and this model has a lot of
parameters
um
so the bird base has like 110 million
parameters and very large model has 330
million
parents so okay so how we can actually
use the bird for the uh for reading
carbon enhancement so it's actually very
easy and very straightforward the idea
is to take the question as a segment a
so you also in the frictions are
two segments for the next sentence
prediction task so when you apply the
verb on the reading comprehension task
you basically just take the question as
a second a and take the passage as a
segment b
and finally the goal is trying to
predict true end point in segment b
so here's one more concrete example so
question is how many parameters does
bird large have so you can see that so
they basically just um take the question
here and then takes a passive here and
by putting in the serious token and the
acp token and by just contacting the
question of passage tokens and also for
the questions that you just need to pass
the a to a segment embeddings and the
for the passage you just need to cut out
put in the
um the second b embeddings
and now finally the training loss is
also the same so you basically just um
try to maximize the probability of the
sum of the natural log likelihood of
both the start and positions
but here's the way that the computer
start and and um
probability is slightly different so
that's very straightforward
so you just pass this um input notation
into birth and the bird can give you the
hidden vector h i that can actually
represent the hidden vector that
corresponding to the context word
context word ci
so you can just
introduce another two vectors w star and
wn by computing the dot product and then
apply the softmax then you can just give
you a very similar to what we had before
but here is the high just output from
the vertical encoder and then we are
training on this tool that we start and
w and to um for these two probability
distribution p start vpn
okay so for this model
so all the vertical transfers that is
actually very large number um if you use
basically 110 million parameters as well
as the newly introduced parameters h
star and h and
uh which is if you take the birth base
so hidden side will be
768 so it's only like 1 500 new
parameters so we just optimized together
jointly for this training objective
and it actually works really really well
this model so
if you just take this modbrate model and
by just optimizing all the parameters
together you can give you very high
performance i will show you in a minute
i know even the strong even if you use
the stronger creation on your
are more than like the
standard um stronger models than the
bird models they can even lead to better
performance and on scope and the score
that has also become a standard dataset
for testing these kind of playtime
models
let me show you some numbers so here
again human performance in 91 and by
that is 77.3
and if we just uh do this functioning
model
so bird base can give you like 88.5 very
large can give you 19.9 so you can see
that this is a huge jump uh from the
badass model to the building models
and then finally if you see the even the
latest um
um pre-translated models include the
exxon robot or albert so these models
are either like a bigger or these
moderate channels bigger covers or the
model size are bigger so basically these
models can
give you give you another like three
four point i i find score compared to
the very large model so this is already
way
higher than the estimate f1 score so
this just works really well
any quick questions
i think this may be okay
okay so
okay so yeah i guess i've been a little
bit fast for this bird models but next
what so i want to also do a bit of the
comparisons between the biodiversity
models and the bird models
so burning model has many many more
planters so it's like either like 110
more million or 330 million branches but
that has only like 2.5 million
parameters
and the by death is built on top of
several bi-directional ios teams and
while bird is built on top of their
transformers so transformer means that
um there isn't any recurrence of
structural architecture so the
transformers are much easier to paralyze
and a very key um difference between the
bird models and by back models is bird
model is a pre-trend but by that model
is only built on top of the glove of
vectors which is a pre-trend and all the
remaining
parameters new people learn from this
called the data set or the other
supervision data set
so here it is very clearly that
pre-training is a game changer
here uh that appreciating basic can just
change everything and also give you a
very very large boost in terms of the
performance
but also i want to raise another
question so if we don't think of this
like um pre-training uh just like by
that mother and birth models are really
fundamentally different
i don't think so because of glory is
actually my argument so let's try to see
how these two models actually connected
especially in terms of model design
so by that model essentially they're
trying to model the interactions between
a question the passage right so both the
question to pass it in the passage of
question
and the first model essentially they're
trying to
use a self-retention
on top of the concatenation of the
question passage so this is a
transformer model so you should take the
question the passage so these are
questions in the passage and then you
apply many many different layers of the
self-attention essentially that this
self-attention is able to capture
the attention
between the context words the attention
between the passage was on the question
words and the attention from the
question to the passive side and also
the attention from between um from the
question was to another other question
words
so compared to you by that by definitely
trying to model this part but the burden
model essentially can capture the
tension between all these four parts
and uh actually after by that kind of so
um just also before the bird can um
before the bird came out so he will have
been also showing that if you just add a
self-potential layer for the passive
site so basically you're trying to
explicitly model this attention between
the passive words and passive words to
the depth this account also improve the
performance so you can see that um these
two models essentially really just
trying to model the tension between the
passive impression and also the
attention between the passwords and the
passwords and this is actually what
exactly the first model is doing
okay
um
so if there's no further questions um so
at this point i talked about um
models can do really well on this kind
of reading comprehension data set and
always talk about
pre-training can really change the
performance can be again changing
reading comprehension
i guess
don't you
add one question first people wonder
whether you can do well
with a transformer that isn't
pre-trained right if you try to build a
question-answering system using a
transformer rather than rsdns but no
pre-training does that work
that's a good question yeah it works but
you you probably cannot really build a
model as big as like 110 million
premiums or 200 uh 330 million
parameters models so actually there is a
model between the um
so
between uh between the this like family
of the ios tn models and burn models
called qa net from google so qr net is
actually built on top of the
transformers with other pre-training so
that model actually can perform better
than the badass models and other models
but they actually
underperform the battery models quite a
bit
so just check it out for qa map
okay i will just continue
so okay so given free training has been
so important so next i will quickly talk
about okay
question here is that can we actually
even design better pre-training
objectives for reading comprehension or
question answering
and the answer is actually yes so this
is actually work i did with mendel josh
and other folks like one year ago called
spambered
so think about this so um for the squad
and other a lot of extractive uh reading
comprehension data set the goal is
trying to predict the answer spam from
the passage uh as a question so the uh
as a answer to this question so there
are two key ideas being proposed in
spamber
the first idea is that instead of using
only the masking of individual words
we propose that we want to master
contiguous extensive words um in the
passage because the final answer would
be just a segment of text in the passage
so we are trying to um so mask out all
these um possible answers then from the
passage as a training objective
and the second idea proposed with
spamberg is that
because at the end of view because we
want to predict unsuspends
so
we're actually essentially trying to
predict two end points
um as an answer so the idea here is that
can we try to compress the two endpoints
of unsuspect
um
sorry can we try to compress all the
information in this span into the two
end points so here's the idea is that
here let's think about this if we mask
out the forwards here and can we try to
use the two end points here in this um
figure like x4 and x line to predict all
the words in the middle so essentially
we are trying to pre uh take the two end
points and also the position some kind
of position encoding and then finally we
are going to try to predict all the
words in this span so this is why this
is called spam bird um so i encourage
you to check out our paper
and this actually really helps a lot uh
at least for the question once again
stuff so
as you can see from this figure so this
is called 1.1 and it's called 2.0 and
these are many other question answering
data sets
as you can see here
um so the
blue bars here we call google versus
actually the um the original checkpoints
are released by google for researchers
and our birth is actually just uh
exactly our re-implementation of the
first model but we are having trying to
using the same data but we have been
trying trying to train this model for
slightly longer so it's actually
achieved a better performance than the
original group
so as you can see that the yellow box
here is actually standard so spammer can
actually uh briefly outperform the blue
version overboard um
across all the data sets that really
tells us that okay even if we don't we
are not going to increase the model size
we are not going to increase the data by
designing better prediction objectives
can also be go a long way and do do a
much better job in at least in the
question answering and reading
comprehension data sets
okay um
so i have like several few slides left
in this part so
so so far i have to demonstrate that um
by using by that model and by using
burden models we can get a very good
performance on the score data set the
resistance number has already exist even
the human performance on scope does this
means that the reading comprehension is
already solved
the answer is of course not
so let me um just so in the recent last
couple of years there's been a lot of
evidence showing that the current system
still performed poorly on anniversary
examples or the examples from the out of
domain distributions
so here is a very classical example
so proposed by robin channel president
in 2017. so the idea is that they take a
pass passage and take a take a question
and they're trying to just insert like a
random sentence uh to the end of the
paragraph as you can see that this
sentence has like even like a nonsense
entity in this context drafting here but
this sentence actually has like a great
uh some left score overlap between the
questions it's actually very similar to
this question but actually the word
numbers have been changed the antennas
has been changed and then they found
that these kind of adverse examples can
actually very easy to fool the current
systems and then the final pro and the
mix assistant to predict answer to the
drafting
so the by um here's the table shows that
by adding a lot of these adversary
examples they found that the performance
actually draws a lot of just by that
model so it drops from 75.5 to even like
30 percent so for even like this kind of
attack the performance will just drop to
very low like 4.8
so here's another paper that actually
just came out in 2020 so it has me a lot
of the evidence showing the similar
things that so today we can build a very
good reading comprehension data set on
individual data on the individual data
sets but this season channel one dataset
physic can already generalize to other
data sets so the diagonal is basically
the of this
table is basically channel one mod to
model one data set and evaluate on the
same data set and for all the other
numbers in this table but it shows that
if you try and run some system on one
data set and then you value it on
another data set the performance will
drop quite a lot so it's basically
really kind of generalized from one data
set to another data set
so finally this is actually a very
interesting um
result so this small this paper is
actually the best paper from acl 2020 is
called checklist paper so the idea is
that this this authors basically try to
propose some kind of
test cases to check whether these models
can actually really unders um
answer some simple questions rather with
some specific or particular phenomena
they find that by just come up with some
really simple questions for example here
jeremy is more optimistic than taylor
and who is more pessimistic
and that's uh they found that a birth
large model channel stop and this is can
still fill this type of test cases 100
percent of time
and now here is another table so you can
see that here is another clever example
like victoria and alex are friends come
on is our agent who's my agent
and um so to get this kind of question
correctly so it has to understand the
pictorial actually refers to a female
person and the alice refers to a male
person so this model this kind of
questions also make some kind of models
very large multiple channels for the
totally film of this kind of test cases
okay um
so i have 10 minutes left
chris is any question actually answer at
this point
i think you can go on
okay so in the last 10 minutes i'm going
to give you a very very brief
introduction of what it opened on my
question answering and what we are have
been trying to do in the last couple
years
so although the main question answering
the problem that um so it's different
from the reading comprehension that we
don't assume a given passage so here
with the assumption that we only have
access to a large collection of
documents so one example is just taking
the whole english wikipedia which has
like five million articles so we don't
really know where the answer is located
and the goal is to return the answer for
any open domain questions so this
problem so there isn't any single
passage so we have to answer questions
against a very large collection document
or even the whole web documents
so this is actually a much more
challenging and also more practical
problem um
so
if you look think about the example of
google example i showed at the beginning
so this will be techniques that will be
very useful in the practical
applications
so the term here open domain is just in
contrast to close domains that deal with
questions under specific difference
under the specific domain yeah
okay so
how can you solve this type of problem
because for the reading comprehension
problem we just need to answer questions
based on single passage so this is a
paper that i wrote in 2017 four years
now so it's called the paper it's called
reading wikipedia pdf to answer all
questions and system called doctor qa so
the
favorite basically proposed the idea
that we can actually solve this problem
by using like a retrieval and also a
reader framework
so idea is that let's take a question
okay so here our goal is to try to
answer questions uh using like a very
large collection of documents such as
the wikipedia so the idea is that
there's a retrieval and also reader
component so the retrieval takes in the
question
and i try to find out like the smaller
number of our documents have to be
relevant to this question
and this reading model basically trying
to read through all the documents that
just retrieval
return and if i try to find out the
correct answer
um so
formally defined here is that the input
is a large collection of documents d and
the question q and the output could be
our answer string a
so we can just decompose this problem
into as i just mentioned in the
retrieval and reader component so the
ritual is basically trying to take the
large collection document d and q and
try to return
a set of documents or set of passages so
here the this number k could be very
small um
could be very small um
such as like um
well just like a 100 so he's basically
trying to pull out a found out like 100
passages or documents um from like of
let's say five million documents
and finally the reader is basically
takes a question and takes this set of
the passages and finally found um
finally return the answer so the second
problem is actually the reading
comprehension model that we just learned
so lean um just search some 17 paper
results so it's actually doing a very
same simple thing so the retrieval is
just a standard uh information trigger
model is a sparse uh pfidf information
through a sparse model and the real
model is essentially just a neural
reading complement comprehension model i
just talked about so it's very trend on
scott and some other questions three
data sets
um so this is really the idea is very
simple but you're trying to bridge the
two things how to how to have bridges
this retrieval and also the reader to do
this kind of open domain question
answering
so
so i'm just going to quickly go over
um some really exciting ideas that um
that has been happening um uh in the
last two years basically so the first
idea is that this retrieval part can be
also trend so we can't actually even do
this kind of join the training of the
retriever on the reader so here is
actually
so this this idea has been first
proposed in canton league's paper in
2019 called legendary retrieval for
weekly supervised open number questions
so this part is basically the first uh
model for reading comprehension and
system apart is basically the retrieval
model so to get this ritual among
working they also try to use the birth
to encode the passage and also you
called the question and they try to use
the dot product between the question
notation and passive representation to
model how
how the relevance so the similarity
between the question the passage but
this is actually very difficult problem
because the scalar scalability of this
problem because there are like 20
million passages in the wikipedia so
it's actually very hard to model this
part but so i encourage you to check out
this paper
and now also on second table i want to
quickly mention it there's also work i
did uh last year um it's called the best
passive view tool so the idea is
actually very similar to
the
previous paper but the idea is that it's
actually much more simplified model and
very easy very simple straightforward
approach the idea is that we can also
really just trend the retrieval part by
using two bird models using only the
question answer pairs
and this motorcycle works really well
and then kind of largely all for the
traditional ir retrieval models if you
see this figure so the blue curve here
is a traditional ir approach um like a
bm25 approach and uh since the other
curve the orange curve is basically
training this kind of retrieval using
only one thousand question answer pairs
so by looking looking at all these
different curves basically using
different number of training examples so
it's actually kind of largely briefly
out from the traditional ir models
um okay so again really i don't have
time to talk about the details of all
these approaches
so i just encourage you to check out
this paper uh papers and i think this
result is really exciting um so here is
actually a really nice demo so you know
the demo is actually um
hosted at this website before you check
out so
again so the database here is the whole
wikipedia you can see that if you ask a
question who tells harry potter that
he's a wizard and the higher in the
harry potter series and the system has
really found out the correct article
should be harry potter film series and
then finally give you the current answer
which is exactly what you have seen from
the google example here so it has the
answer it could be the rubrics calgary
which is actually the person who tells
harry potter that he's a wizard so this
is exactly the perfect answer to this
question
okay i'm going to escape this slide
and then finally um very quick so
so this is something that came out uh
various uh recently that some
researchers have demonstrated that maybe
you don't even need this retrieval study
so you can if you just use a very large
language model you can also just do the
open domain question answering uh so the
way they did this is that i hope that
you have learned the t5 model in this
class already so they just take a
preaching language model g5 and they are
trying to find through this model by
taking the question and taking the
question of the input as an answer as of
without any explicit retrieval and they
just fine tune this on the data set and
they find this model can do pretty well
at the testing time by just taking the
question and then directly generates
answers without the resorting to any
like documents or like a retrieval
system so this is actually very amazing
so this kind of model is also called
called crossbow qa systems
okay very uh the last life so
so just one direction and personally i'm
very excited about
so
this is actually a new direction that
basically shows that maybe for the
online domain question answering maybe
this real model is also not necessary
anymore
so
so this idea was first proposed by
museum in 2019 and we recently wrote a
paper called dance phrases just to try
to demonstrate that
maybe you don't even need this like a
reader model so instead we can just
encode all the phrases in wikipedia
using some kind of dance vectors so what
you just need to do is just to do this
kind of nearest neighbor search in the
answer space you just encode all encode
all the phrases in wikipedia encodes and
using vectors and by taking a question
you can just encode this question using
a vector and then we can just do the
vector the nearest neighbor search
and then you can directly give you the
answer so this is a new paragraph of
this kind of the question answering
model so you don't need them you just
need a retrieval you don't need a reader
so a great advantage for doing this is
that so
for the perfect reader model essentially
you have to run a better model at the
inference time this is actually very
expensive
but you can just get rid of this model
you can just do the similarity search
you can just do the nearest new research
without the running of bird model so
this could be very fast and can even run
on the cpus without like leading to
like a very expensive deep neural
network and you can still run very well
perform very very well
okay finally i hope this works so i
actually prepared uh demo for this
transferences so i want to show you how
this actually works
so you can see that after you type this
question who won the not nobel prize in
peace in 2014 so every time just time
for like a little piece of the input
question and then the system can
basically just find out the relevant um
answer in the relevant text passages and
then finally on the answer it actually
shows up it's actually very fast because
it's a bit of real time we don't we
don't remember on the birth model so
it's just a reassurance here
okay i'm actually done this is lecture
so that's
5 15 now yeah
thanks for joining me today
thank you very much dante for that
awesome survey of um
question answering i guess given that
demo at the end people want to know
whether you're launching your own search
engine soon um
but um
um at any rate um don chi can stay for a
bit to answer questions
but not forever but um today um because
of you know she doesn't have a stanford
login we're going to do questions inside
zoom so if you'd like to ask a question
if you use the raise hand button
we can promote you so that you appear in
the regular zoom window and can just ask
questions and
see each other and if you hang around
and don't
leave the zoom for more than a few
minutes maybe we'll just promote
everybody who's still there into um
people in the regular zoom um for
some bits of discussion but um we'd
welcome anyone who'd like to ask a
question
by asking it themselves at this point
okay
i've got one volunteer
i've got more volunteers
should i meet some questions oh should i
look at the chat or oh no i mean so
there are now four people who've been
promoted um
there are four people
was the first so maybe um he could start
by asking a question and then the other
people that we've um
promoted okay
uh so thank you so much for the lecture
today uh my question is mainly like if
you use like a model like uh for example
how uh small
can your training um
data set be for you to get like
reasonable results
so the question is how we can try the
comprehension and model using only a
small number of returning examples
yeah i think this is a really good
question um
especially
like the you probably have heard the gpt
stream model that you've shown that if
you only use a few uh very few examples
you can also do the open domain question
answering pretty well
so i but this kind of model is huge like
um
what's the number like um
how many parameters i forgot in the gpu
stream model yeah so it's a very large
very cute model but by okay so basically
my answer is that
if we can leverage a very large and very
powerful prediction language model there
is a way that we um there is a
possibility that we can actually do the
question string with um well with only a
small number examples
and now also there are some other
promising directions including like
unsupervised questions three
so by using some kind of approach like
the
from the machine uh unsupervised machine
translation this kind of idea that can
be borrowed and the by um
yeah comparison ideas from that um
can also work pretty well reasonable
reasonably well in unsupervised
questions
um
yeah also i have seen some a lot of
works like very busy showing that uh uh
synthetic qrdss can also
help a lot um in boosting the
performance if you don't have enough uh
supervised datasets i also have nice
examples yeah
so my question is it's i guess it's kind
of interesting that there's not really
that strong
of a transfer effect um between data
sets that are
kind of ostensibly similar so my
question is like
has there been any research done on
how close i guess like the formatting
and the
uh semantic content of these question
answering data sets actually adheres to
the data that like burt is pre-trained
on
um and if so like has there been sort of
any effect found between
those similarities or differences
i it's a question asking like whether
there has been like a song
okay maybe i can just try to
clarify a little bit why the current
models can already generalize well from
one data set to another days that we've
um yeah so
i actually really believe that uh most
existing question answering dataset or
reading comprehension dataset have been
collected um from mechanic perk so it's
very hard it's very difficult to avoid
some kind of artifact or like a simple
clues or super visual code that easier
let's say not superficial but some
simple clues that for the machines to
pick up
so for
let's take those folders examples that
so you can see that actually if you look
at the data set more closely there has
been a lot of examples as a question
having like a large
overlap in terms of words between the
question the passage so the model is
actually very good at picking up these
kind of clues to get a very high
performance on this data set
and another data set is called um
drop so it's basically about the
comparison the two numbers something
like that so that's the reason that uh
one specialized model that has been
checked very well in a one-on-one data
set it's very easy to pick up this uh
this kind of course and it's very hard
to generalize this kind of thing to
another deficit
what about the natural questions data
set doesn't that avoid that objection
yeah natural
questions will be uh much better but
there are some other issues i'm not sure
if you have seen that
uh there's a recent paper called like a
question uh trend test overlap
paper so that means a demonstration i
used to interrupt so natural questions
was a data set that google put out about
a year and a half ago maybe um where
they were actually taking real questions
from google search logs and then
finding answers trying to find answers
for them in web documents sorry go on
dutchy
oh i just don't think yeah i think it's
definitely natural questions is much
better than i said because the questions
are natural like you're collected uh i
really like real questions that are
asking by like the users so it kind of
avoids this kind of superficial artifact
between the question and passage but
there is some other issues that um
people like to ask some common questions
so if you just do the random spate of
the questions into trend diving test
and there's a recent paper video showing
that there is actually a you know busy
model is inevitable that there is a
higher overlap between the training
staff so if you find this question if
one question that you're trying to test
uh um in the desktop or the test set
that household already appears in the
change that that is not really
generalization right
yeah but this is the more on the like
open domain setting not in the reading
comprehension section yeah
yeah um
do you wanna ask a question
yes so you mentioned that uh in the last
part of the presentation is that the
reader model is may not be necessary and
you presented the dance phrases which
can also work well on cpus so
do we know how um how well it performs
on the question answering data sets
and compared to other compared to other
models including birds and sources
on gpu of course
yeah i just encourage you to check out
this paper so this this model is
basically
performs on par with like the dance
pattern retrieval paper uh retrieval
model so it's uh either
performs on part of these are all the
ritual reader models but it is actually
right now though so i skipped one slide
so so right now the saved art is
actually uh dominating by this kind of
uh dense passive retrieval positive
generating model
so this kind of so using a t5 model plus
a that's a retrieval this is actually
performed really well so i will just say
so this can work this is similar um in
this block but compared to this kind of
generating model we still like a few
points behind yeah
okay and uh
what is the kind of the uh
intuition behind the dance phrases
apart from like the answers are probably
um in close proximity and what if the
data says
has answers and quest has answers to a
specific question like very far
uh from the actual information
like see the answers to the question may
not be may not reside in close proximity
to the um
to the words in the question
so let me just clarify this um
okay the goal of this project is trying
to
um index all the phrases in the
wikipedia
so
i know by under this kind of rotations
are built using the training set of the
question answering data sets
so the assumption is still the
distribution of the examples in the
different tests that will be similar to
the training set for sure
does this answer your question like so
basically we're still trying to consider
all the phrases in wikipedia and that
test now we just take the questions and
try to complete the dot product okay
so if we use say a different
dataset that does not present the
information using a structure presented
in wikipedia then um this model may not
work as well as
what what do you mean by structure then
so uh say if we um
lean more towards clearly more towards
uh structures like the passages we see
in standardized tests where the answers
to the question
may not be like
um may not be in close proximity to
where the
the information was first introduced oh
no so the the answers doesn't have to be
seen in the training step so the
business are going to taking the
training set channel encoder for the
phrases and by using and then we apply
this encoder to all the free all the
places all the a lot of like six meter
phrases in this video so so the model is
definitely able to generalize from the
um training set to all the phrases to
use media so it doesn't have to be
seeing the things that
is this what are you asking
i see okay
this is actually very so it's actually
similar to like the retrieval or the
best passive retrieval so you still like
um
yeah i tried to channel a passive
rotation here in the first station but
so the rotation is only a trend using
the training set of the question
answering data sets
but um by taking the encoder and then we
are going to encode uh all the rotations
all the passages of phrases in wikipedia
and then we can um expect that this
rotation can actually generalize well
for the unseen questions
yeah
so uh so that so the question is um
what if the nearest neighbor so she
doesn't return the answer
so why do you think the nearest neighbor
i mean you always can find something
right it's just the question is that
whether it calls him up or not
yes so the sort of question is what do
you think the data says that the answer
is not close enough then
um
yeah that's good question i don't know
uh if you really come up with something
that is really very far away from
all the questions that we have been uh
seeing in the training center that could
be possible i don't know
basically depend on uh
how the texts are um formatted
then uh the nearest neighbor search may
not uh work as well as other models
so again the question is also the
question invitation is also returned by
a question code
so
so the question is whether this question
coder can give you something reasonable
in that space or not
but i don't know yeah so we have been
testing a lot of like a random even the
imported sentences or even
the question doesn't have to be a real
question it could be a sentence it
doesn't seem to be our problem so far
yeah
maybe maybe we should give a couple of
other people a go and you're allowed to
turn your camera on or ask a question if
you want um so our next person
all right hi uh thank you for taking the
time to teach us um my my question is
kind of quick so you mentioned work that
brought up a set of relatively simple
questions that show how brittle or poor
the current models can be
right i'm curious if that's true
yeah yeah exactly
exactly did that trigger a big change in
the community to
improve how to evaluate the models
because they're actually doing pretty
poorly on some of those right
yeah so first these questions are simple
in uh in terms of the
the wording is very simple the template
is very simple but they're still trying
to test like a negation or temporal
relational preference so the questions
are not
i mean in terms of the reasoning of the
capacity it's not that simple just the
wording very simple
um
i do think um okay so this paper
definitely received a lot of attention
in the best paper last year at acl the
biggest country in the conference
um so i think a lot of people are trying
to solve the problem
i cannot tell you that okay whether we
really have a solution to this yeah oh
no yeah
cool yeah thank you thank you for
bringing this one up it's really
interesting
okay next is
hi thanks for taking this time so my
question is kind of not relevant but
like to build a robust system of
question answering
in what extent can in-context learning
help models to be more robust with
respect to different domains
oh so like uh basically you provide a
template generated by bird and then
instead of directly predicting the
clauses of text classifications you just
use some word to represent that clause
okay
so i assume that you are actually
referred to the in-context learning
industry industry
stuff like that
okay um actually i've been doing
something related to dynamic recently uh
so but i'm not sure how we can actually
use that in context learning in any
scene for school type you know problems
um
yeah so i don't know if that could be
robustness or not i even thought you
used that technique for the questions
three years
i see i see thanks and i used to also
mention that we can train a retriever
without a reader so is there a paper
about the current
like attempt to do that
yeah so so favorite already off so just
uh yeah okay
okay next
hey how's it is uh thanks so much for
the uh for the lecture um i'm gonna have
a broader question um
about the future of nlp
um
do you think that in order to
solve nlp in a sense that
you can perform on par with humans on
all nlp tasks it's sufficient to only
interact with text data whatever do you
think will eventually need some sort of
sort of experience and common sense that
you get um only from seeing and sort of
feeling the world and having the sorts
of interactions that we as humans have
yeah i mean common senses have been very
difficult even in the context of
constraining common sense is a very
yeah now very very important topics that
uh still remains i think it still
remains on the result
uh that's
for that part the honest exactly yes
i also want to mention that
okay so for a lot of the reading
comprehension databases or questions
that you're seeing that we are pure with
people start starting to achieve the
human performance but this but we also
see that how great of these systems are
because yeah i mean they cannot
regenerate or solve the easy problems so
all these things need to be resolved
um
[Music]
trying to have a human in the loop um
a framework to evaluate these kind of
systems just try to uh break the current
system come back with some harder
questions
so um
yeah so that means that maybe the kind
of static businesses are not good enough
to measure the progress so we actually
really need some kind of dynamic
evaluation and
also introduce all more this kind of
adverse examples or the
um yeah harder questions or something
like that
are you still going for a couple more
questions
uh sure i don't want to make sure it's
nine or 9 10 p.m uh yeah on the east
coast yeah
okay
um so next is nexus
in
nerfs 2020 there was this efficient open
domain question answering challenge um
and
from you know from performance it seemed
like there was like quite substantial uh
decrease versus human accuracy
um probably like
primarily the quantization and um
also some drift that occurred
when they were quantizing
um so
i i recently encountered this paper
called uh learnable quantizers uh which
essentially
learns
uh learns like basis representations for
the quantizers like jointly with the
weights of the network um
and
while this would be like extremely
effective if you were to just like say
trains from scratch i was just very
curious do you think that like such a
there are some way
[Music]
um yeah i don't think i i'm really
expert to answer that question um
yeah i'm not sure if i really have the
answer but i also want to quickly
mention that yeah quantization has been
very very useful technique to make the
model smaller right so we have been also
exploring the contaction in in the dance
phrases project recently because of the
storage has been
still very uh has been still very large
so we are having trying to reduce that
story
um
yeah i'm not sure about the is there a
question about the connection between
composition and also training
uh yeah i'm not sure i'm
i've also do that yeah sorry yeah thank
you
thanks the dante was too
modest to mention that she was one of
the co-organizers of the efficient qa um
shared task um okay next question is
hi guys you thanks so much for being
here today um
so my question is uh a bit different um
so one example you gave that call my
attention was this alex victoria example
the checklist um and i was thinking
technically alex was in the wrong answer
right it's gender neutral and there
wasn't enough context context in the
question to determine who it's referring
to so my question is how concerned
should we be about potentially
encoding uh certain biases into these
circle labels or how we evaluate them or
is that just more of a concern for more
open-ended questions
um
yeah this is definitely very important
again like a lot of a lot of people are
trying to study okay how much buyers
have been coping with models and how we
can
yeah um
yeah i'm not sure if i have a good
answer to that um
again like i just i want to say like how
to do the biasing of the creation
language models all these things are
very important
and um
um
yeah this is just one so you're talking
about this example right so this is just
one test case
um yeah um
yeah i i don't know yeah
right yes i guess i'm just a little more
about you know who comes up with the
test cases right who determines the
other yes there is
thank you
i mean we will we will have more
discussion of toxicity in bias coming up
very soon including actually thursday's
lecture as well as the later lecture um
not specifically about qa though um okay
next person is
right thank you for the lecture um
yeah my question is also related to the
open domain uh classroom history so um
um i was just wondering how much of like
uh the uh learning side of um
uh domain like sort of generalization um
or like domain alignments um techniques
can be uh
combined with like the language um level
like questioning string like to what
extent would they work and
um like what kind of like language
specific design should be leveraged to
combine with those to
sort of like um if we want like higher
performance and stuff like that
there's a question about how to
generalize between different domains or
uh let's talk about how to design uh
open domain qa system for different
languages i'm not sure
so there's like uh
some some uh like learning specific
designs like um
um
uh domination alignments and like a
future level disentanglement techniques
uh
that have been that has shown some like
like uh interesting performance on um
other tasks um and i saw that like
recently some people also like leverage
similar things um like for for for
question answering so i was just
wondering um like to what extent uh
these kind of techniques um come work on
um like uh language tasks not just
limited question answering but like um
mainly um question answering
sorry what which which work are you
talking about i'm not still not sure
what do you mean by this entire
conversations or questions right so uh
so basically um
i mean this is like a little bit more
specific for so um so there's this um
paper called um
uh doing um
i forgot the exact name uh
okay so i have okay i just want to make
sure that we are on the same page so i
have things that work instead of trying
to learn some kind of in disintegration
so i can better generalize to the
different domains or adverse examples is
this what you're saying
yeah yeah
and the question is that this technique
can be a general general generally
applied to personal strength oh um yeah
they're just wondering how um to what
extent would they work because
um i think language has like
a lot of like specific things like
dependency and other stuff that like
these techniques does not like actually
um take care of so i was just
uh
yeah um
yeah i'm not sure uh i think we have to
try that but that's a interesting point
yeah i don't know at least for the work
that i've seen so far all
are applied or operated at a very simple
uh sentence classification task maybe
anonymous uh maybe seven or correct
so
my understanding is as a basic take a
level encoder applied to a simple test
classification task and take a hidden
rotation do some kind of
or transformation and make sure that
um yeah it can learn some kind of
environmental features from the hidden
reputation something like that
right yeah cool
yeah i'm not sure i feel like qa is a
more structured task and also handles
longer
uh sequences
um
yeah so i don't know if it works uh
unless people have tried that yeah
thank you thank you okay and then we've
got and maybe we should call this the
last question
hi um i'm just wondering what is like
the intuitive difference between
solving question answering with uh
guaranteed models like t5 versus
encoders like bird
okay um that's the point oh okay so i'm
so i skipped this slide so
why this model works so well uh the
reason is actually it's not really about
the extracting model versus generating
model the reason is that
they actually um for the extracting
model
so if the retrieval returns let's say
100 passages so they have to extract the
answer from each of the passages and
then finally figure out which one is the
max what has the highest score but for
the generating model essentially they're
trying to aggregate all the 100 passages
and their reputations together and do
their generation um jointly do you
understand
so essentially taking the 100 stations
together to the joint generation instead
of only do the extraction from each of
the passages so i think that's actually
the key difference so that's why this
generating model can do really well
compared to the
extracting models so i also want to
mention that okay
so if you look at this ig model it's
actually um
like a comparison dpi and rhg model so
ig model is always doing the generative
model but they are not doing this kind
of aggregation they're just trying to
take out a single passage and doing the
generation so the rng model actually
doesn't perform as well as this model by
the way i also want to mention rng model
is actually not doing better than dpr
because this base model is large model
so this these numbers are a little bit
confusing so they're actually basically
really on par they're basically
performed similarly but um so the the
key difference between the generating
model and the extracting model is that
for general models you can actually
leverage more com on input passage
together and do the generation
does this that is that clear or not um
yes
yeah thanks
yeah otherwise you should just check out
this paper here so this paper actually
started pretty well then why this model
can work better than the previous
generating models
[Music]
models to
oh
encoders is like
you're finding similarities between
their encodings
uh and then generate models are you like
remembering the whole question
and
you try to
retrieve that mainly like
when you answer the question
okay so for this model there isn't any
retrieval
so you cannot really find the answer
from a question right
so this model really has to rely on all
the parameters to memorize all the
information
so by just taking this input it has to
just rely on the branches to infer this
answer
so it's actually very hard too so yeah
it's definitely balanced between
memory and a generalization
i see so um
i'm just gonna uh
say what i like is it like when you give
got this question is embedding it in
some space and then
using that embedding the generator
matches that to like
1882 is that what is going on in there
yes
the model has like it's very large like
a
11 billion parameters so all these the
parameters are basically trying to
uh yeah memorize a lot of information
that has been because the model has been
pretty
from the text and also has been
fine-tuned so the model has been trying
to memorize all the information from the
text yes
um do you want to call it an idol do you
want one more question
uh either way yeah
it's up to you
i'm sure i'm happy to take one more
question okay let me just do okay
one more question from
okay uh the first question is about how
how easily are these techniques
generalized to
other languages
i like to say languages that are quite
different quite different grammatical
rules like chinese
japanese or
arabic or some other languages
sort of another
question maybe not exactly your domain
expertise is
there's a lot of interest in modeling
user behavior say unlike searching
behavior browsing behavior as a sequence
using say transformers self-attention
um and then you can use that to predict
how user can like embed the user as a
vector
and can predict user's actions
how promising do you think that would be
i know this may not be your domain
expertise but there is a lot of interest
in extending these uh
plus answering techniques are just
encoding techniques embedding techniques
to
recommend our systems
um
just want to
get your thoughts on
okay um the first question is whether
these techniques can be generalized to
other languages i think it's honestly uh
yes and there has been a lot of active
research in this fashion but there has
been also some constraints that um as a
lot of models or systems i described
here actually require a lot of them
require very strong like a pre-trained
language model and also requires a lot
of training samples for the pure idss
so that would be actually um
i would say a bottleneck for many low
resource languages right
so
so it's very hard to collect so many
examples for other languages
if we have actually i think the
techniques can check can be generalized
generally applied to other languages as
and there has been also a lot of work
trying to do like cross-lingual
questions through stuff like that